Ella kannst du Kuchen probieren
es gibt Biskuitrolle
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
mein Team hat sich mal wieder ein
nachgemacht Video gewünscht und zwar die
Coppenrath und Wiese sahnerolle in der
Geschmacksrichtung Schwarzwälder Kirsch
das ist diese hier ich muss zugeben dass
ich die noch nie gegessen habe aber ich
finde generell dass die Coppenrath und
Wiese Torten und bis mit Rollen die
sehen halt immer so perfekt aus also ich
liebe diese Oberfläche und ich liebe sie
der Biskuit dann aussieht ähm probieren
werden was gleich ich habe die
Zutatenliste jetzt auch schon gecheckt
und ich meine das sind einfach Zutaten
drin die eben in Torten und Kuchen sind
die man aus dem Tiefkühlfach holt oder
aus dem Kühlschrank wenn man was frisch
zubereitet braucht man keine
Konservierungsstoffe und keine
Zitronensäure z.B aber wenn man
natürlich was auf den Vorrat herstellt
im Kühlfach oder im Gefrierfach braucht
man natürlich ein paar Dinge die man
jetzt zu Hause nicht benutzen würde wie
zum Beispiel
Vollmilchpulver
wie zum Beispiel
oder süßmolkepulver oder
Feuchthaltemittel was aber alles gar
nicht schlimm ist das ist in fast allen
Produkten drin die man eben fertig
kaufen kann also nichts schlimmes
nichtsdestotrotz zeige ich euch heute
wie ihr diese Biskuitrolle zu Hause
selbst nachmachen könnt
ich bin mal gespannt drauf die sehen
halt echt immer perfekt aus ich will das
jetzt meine auch super perfekt wird ich
bin gespannt jedenfalls werde ich jetzt
hier einen Schokoladenbiskuit herstellen
und dieses Muster da oben das kriegen
wir auch da habe ich überlege mir gleich
was ich sage euch mal eben kurz die
Zutaten für die Biskuitrolle dafür
verwende ich vier Eier 100 g Zucker
etwas Salz und Vanilleextrakt 100 g Mehl
da habe ich jetzt mein backmehl ihr
könnt auch normales Weizenmehl nehmen
und 30 g Kakao die darf noch ein
bisschen Auftauen denn die war aus dem
TK
aber ich stelle sie auch gleich in den
Kühlschrank okay den Ofen habe ich schon
vorgeheizt auf 210 Grad ober Unterhitze
hier habe ich einen Backrahmen
eingestellt damit backt sich am besten
und am besten verrührt ihr jetzt erstmal
die Eier mit dem Zucker Salz und
Vanilleextrakt in der Rührschüssel für
etwa 4 bis 5 Minuten schön weiß cremig
perfekt
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier Kakao und ich nehme
nicht alles für den Teig denn es gibt ja
diese dunklen Streifen das heißt ein
bisschen was vom Kakaopulver
die Hälfte
nehme ich für die Streifen und die
andere Hälfte kommt in den Teig mit dem
Mehl zusammen
[Musik]
dann vorsichtig unterheben
und die andere Hälfte des Kakaos
verrühre ich mit etwas Wasser zu einer
Paste
noch größere Schüssel jetzt auch getan
einfach so dass eine dickflüssige Masse
entsteht die man aber dann beim
Spritzbeutel aufspritzen kann dann nehme
ich jetzt hier meinen Backrahmen und da
kommt jetzt erstmal die Biskuitmasse
rein und die backt ja dann und die
Oberfläche ist dann später auch außen
auf der Rolle das heißt ich kann dann
dieses Muster hier auf die Oberfläche
schön aufspritzen das passt dann ganz
gut und ich hoffe es klappt auch so
[Musik]
die Kakaomasse fülle ich jetzt in den
Spritzbeutel ein den Spritzbeutel könnt
ihr immer in so ein Glas Stulpen so
einen kleinen spritzbeutelständer habe
ich nämlich ein
ich habe nur den
und jetzt muss es schnell gehen damit
der Biskuit nicht zusammenfällt dann
will nämlich eigentlich immer direkt in
den Backofen also vorne eine kleine
Spitze weg und dann spritze ich jetzt
hier die Streifen rein und dann nehme
ich hier diese Stäbchenprobe und damit
ziehe ich dann das Muster rein
[Musik]
nein
das kommt jetzt in den Backofen für etwa
8 bis 9 Minuten bei 210 Grad ober
Unterhitze
und zwar hatten wir neulich das Problem
wir haben ja echt viele Waschmaschinen
im Haushalt weil wir hier im Studio
waschen bei uns dann oben also überall
weil viele Handtücher und alles mögliche
und man reinigt ja Waschmaschinen immer
regelmäßig unten hat so ein Filter falls
ihr das noch nicht wusstet hier ein Tipp
von mir unten gibt es diesen Filter und
manchmal verhakt sich das weil zum
Beispiel Haarklammern Geld Münzen
Schlüssel Schrauben alles mögliche da
unten reinkommt und man kriegt es nicht
mehr auf und viele wenden dann Gewalt an
und dann geht's halt kaputt und jetzt
hat der Papa der Spezialist einen
Schlüssel für uns gemacht mit dem wird
es auch bekommen
so sieht die Biskuitplatte jetzt aus ich
finde die ist echt schön ich nehme die
jetzt aber direkt aus der Backform raus
damit der Biskuit quasi nicht weiter
gart und nicht austrocknet denn das ist
oft das Problem dass Biskuit Rollen
reisen können wenn sie eben zu trocken
sind deswegen kurz backen und direkt
rausnehmen
dann sauberes Geschirrtuch nehmen
und da drauf stürzen
[Musik]
auf
und kann die Biskuitrolle abkühlen
lassen jetzt habe ich hier die Zutaten
für die Kirschfüllung dafür verwende ich
150 Gramm Kirschen aus dem Glas 300
Gramm Kirschsaft aus dem Glas 40 Gramm
Stärke 30 g Zucker und etwas
Vanilleextrakt ich verrühre jetzt hier
die stärke mit etwas Kirschsaft mit dem
Zucker Vanilleextrakt und den Kirschen
und wird einfach so lange verrührt bis
alles gut aufkocht
[Musik]
die Kirschfüllung steht jetzt kalt jetzt
kann ich hier die sahne Creme zubereiten
dafür habe ich mich jetzt dazu
entschlossen eine quarksahne zu machen
denn ich finde nur Sahne schmeckt mir
manchmal zu sahnig und quarksahne ist so
richtig so im perfekten Ausgleich dafür
verwende ich 250 g Quark etwas Anapher
zum steif schlagen und etwas Zitronen
Abrieb denn Zitronenabrieb passt
wirklich ganz perfekt dazu es gibt ja
erstmal den Quark in die Rührschüssel
Puderzucker und Vanilleextrakt dazu und
rührt die Zutaten kurz durch
[Musik]
dann gerne ein bisschen Zitronenabrieb
nicht so viel
denn es soll keine Zitronencreme werden
sondern nur so leicht aromatisch
[Musik]
perfekt
dann würde ich sagen die sahne Creme
steht die packe ich kurz in den
Kühlschrank bis die Kirschfüllung auch
abgekühlt ist und dann füllen wir gleich
die Torte
jetzt hier die Biskuitplatte auseinander
es wird schön
da kommt jetzt die Creme rein
und ich nehme dann immer gern so eine
Winkelpalette da kann ich nämlich die
Creme hier schön verteilen und eine
Teigkarte für den Rand da kommt hier die
Creme nämlich nicht über den Rand
[Musik]
schön die Kirschfüllung drüber verteilen
immer so ein bisschen bis zum Rand und
ihr seht auch hier bei der Biskuitrolle
ist es echt richtig schön wenn man mit
dem Backrahmen arbeitet wenn man dann
wirklich ein perfektes Rechteck hat wo
kein Verschnitt ist wenn man so ein
herkömmliches Backblech nimmt da hat es
so Abrundungen und die habe ich
tatsächlich mal weggeschnitten bei der
Biskuitrolle weil sonst nicht perfekt
aussieht und man hat so ein Anfang und
Ende was wegkommt und hier hat man
einfach eine Rolle die direkt schon
perfekt ist und jetzt einfach mit Hilfe
des Tuches schön vorsichtig auf Holz
[Musik]
ich packe jetzt noch ein bisschen ein da
kommt zu fett wenn eine Stunde in den
Kühlschrank bis sie probieren können
aber ich finde das sieht schon mal ganz
gut aus
[Musik]
okay jetzt können wir die beiden Rollen
vergleichen ich glaube optisch sieht man
schon deutlich in Unterschied okay
Samira möchte probieren
Wiese also Konditorei Coppenrath und
Wiese oder Konditorei Murat der Riese
okay komm optisch gesehen ist die schon
natürlich schöner weil sie halt perfekt
aussieht das ist doch so krass weil
diese bisschen Betreuung die haben immer
so eine perfekte Oberfläche aber es ist
auch wenn man ich hatte immer so ein
Biskuit perfekt so ein bisschen zum
Anrühren habe den mal ausprobiert da
wird es auch so perfekt vielleicht
müssen wir auch so eine Biskuit gelingen
sichere biskuitmischung mal machen und
da hat man immer so ein bisschen zack
zack und es sieht immer perfekt aus ja
okay wir probieren
jetzt also doch
willst du auch probieren
gut okay wir schneiden das jetzt hier
mal weg aber ich finde kommt das Muster
ist schon schön das gut gelungen
wird die probieren wir auch
und wir müssen auch nicht sagen was wir
müssen auch nicht sagen ob jetzt was
besser oder schlechter oder so ist wir
sagen einfach was uns schmecken lassen
und nicht schmeckt und wenn beides
schmeckt es auch okay
schneiden sich halt auch so smooth immer
durch
und die sieht auch immer so gut aus
also wenn man die länger kühlen lässt
dann ist die auch perfekt rund ist immer
nur sagen ja
ich probiere jetzt mal die
ist halt schön locker
und was sagt ihr lecker
es gut
wenn man das ganze natürlich so ein
bisschen mehr
Schwarzwälder kirschmäßig machen will
kann man natürlich noch Kirschwasser
dazugeben aber machen wir hier natürlich
nicht ich finde halt fertig Kuchen haben
manchmal so ein künstlichen Geschmack
aber ich finde aber nicht schlecht man
schmeckt halt dass er fertig ist ne das
ist halt so eine fertige Mischung ist
[Musik]
ja die selbstgemacht
optischen Punkt würde ich an die geben
ja aber geschmacklich würde ich beiden
Punkt geben
aber keine Sorge kannst es auch super ja
okay für einen schönen Kaffeeklatsch
würde ich schon die Rolle selber machen
ich bin nicht so der Fan von fertigen
Kuchen und Torten aber sie schmecken
nicht schlecht also gar nicht schlecht
wir könnten aber machen so ein Format er
fertig Kuchen fertig Torten und die
aufpimpen was man so damit alles machen
kann und ganz schnell was richtig
leckeres zu zaubern und jeder denkt dann
etwas Eigenes gemacht
also ich finde das Rezept super
ich hätte auch gerne dass sie optisch
noch schöner aussehen aber ich finde so
sind mit aus das Rezept findet ihr auf
Sallys blog.de und wenn ihr auch einen
Lieblingskuchen habt aus dem
Tiefkühlfach oder aus dem Kühlfach und
sagt Sally mach doch mal das Rezept nach
dann schreibt einfach in die Kommentare
was soll ich als nächstes nachmachen es
kann auch gerne was herzhaftes sein
viel Spaß dabei
und bis zum nächsten Mal
tschüss
[Musik]
[Applaus]